sono dai altro episodio con la
playstation perché ho una skin che
effettivamente merita di essere fatta
vedere
ed è questa va walter nel senso che sono
un cesso però speriamo di che battuta di
me quindi ragazzi speriamo non far
pagare almeno questo comunque nella
playstation ragazzi appurato è più
faccia come me perché la gente gioca uno
perché gioca scasso e due perché sulla
processione gratis il gioco quindi lo
scaricano tutti anche quelli che non
gliene frega niente mi sono messo la
play più fasce dove però io ve lo giuro
che nelle live sono veramente messo male
a livello di cava cà fatevi i vostri
allora no no no ragazzi stiamo
scherzando ovviamente rai è un auto
giustificazione per cercare di andare
meglio cosa che non so se riesco a fare
quando sono su pc comunque noto che
effettivamente quando sono in live
faccio sempre più cagare perché è
l'ansia la prestazione perché mi stanno
riprendendo la in quel momento perché mi
sto riprendendo la salita e ci sono in
live in diretta quando ve li registro io
vado molto meglio non si sa perché a
questa cosa in tutti i giochi e non in
folgarida basta dai da mountain sta
dicendo non ho capito bene il
personaggio che utilizzo io che razza di
skin e perché se ci fate caso ragazzi
non so non so se un mammut
non ho mai capito comunque quello che ho
sulla playstation 4
non so se è paragonabile a quello per pc
perché soffice una skin abbastanza
carina però su playstation 4
quest'acqua secondo me la batte ancora
la mia dice pc è solo un po più rara
tu hai praticamente rivela vedersi
comunque che bella con la lattina
insomma su quella bellissimo per un
cazzo si trova niente va bene che poi
farà mica puoi farmi l'acqua anzi sì che
puoi fare miracoli a giocare tuo sblocca
me la petizione ragazzi per far giocare
giampiero con il mio account da
mezzanotte alle 6 del mattino tutti i
giorni per il boca mille schifosamente
sto scherzando
o forse non la vediamo questa edizione
bloc party è il gioco dove viene
eliminata più gente che riesco a fare
meglio perché non venga mai stato
eliminato fatti perché basta usare la
tattica come sempre ce la faccio vedere
e adesso come minimo di questa cosa e
caso tantissimo che non aveva niente
soul classico ripa vj
il problema è che la gente sta troppo
indietro anzi ha testato questo io
perché se state davanti bloc party è
molto molto molto più facile perché
vedete che riuscita a schivare molto
prima gli ostacoli la difficoltà ragazzi
stanno sta nello stallo indietro perché
sei stato indietro la gente si ammazza
e se si ammassa vi butta giù la gente
con il problema già a metà ripresa è
stata eliminata e ragazze madri caso ci
fate caso prova ben 11 22
la metà della gente è stata limina del
progetto venne eliminata 7 un sacco di
gente non ho mai capito perché
probabilmente next
speriamo se fai la palla of all bowl o
hexagon o il bollo e se non facciamo la
finale perché ci sta che mi faccia fare
una sentina le peep toe anche in teak
tom e la cavo parecchio bene perché
l'importante è sempre la stessa regola
che vi dico da quando iniziato a giocare
non siate i primi che non serve a nulla
a meno che non vogliate ciao marco
semprevivo mi fa piacere
a meno che non vogliate tra yard aree
nel senso
e arrivare proprio primi in tutti i mini
giochi quindi magari potete potrei
andare ma andare primi questo gioco è
veramente disteso state questo come
faccio io state dietro un proprio
indietro è molto molto più utile che sta
in avanti perché se stati davanti la
kadett e non tanto perché voi cadete ma
perché voi valete garnier non sto
scherzando ragazzi battuta altalene
nonostante l'ultima piattaforma come
questi perché di tanto perché cadete voi
ma perchè vi spingono se la gente mi
spinge cadette uguale quindi rimanete un
per indietro non sto facendo io però non
spingete uguale ma non le ragazze di
ammazzare tutti
non è vero attraverso ti voglio bene
broca di ecco toglietemi ce l'ho fatta
bene bene a rimanere sempre per indietro
gli altri si sacrifica non è mai
arrivata vita non arrivate ma i primi
tutto questo questa tattica ma arrivate
l'importante è arrivare tanto che cos'è
che dicono fermate che mente col monte
sempre infatti marco di vaio fammi
vincere anche lui a latina [ __ ] comunque
va i giochi non sono caduto il primo
gradino è tanto perché il genere caso
purché nostri passo di qua intorno
bravissimi sacro di tutti dietro dio
oddio non è che ce la faccio
ce la faccio un cazzo di latta perché
c'è una testa però ce la posso fare
bravo bravo alessio che gli ha tappato
il percorso by zio di mezzo di mezzo ha
sinora perfetto mica di gara perfetto o
anche se non santo subito
ti prego
se va bene va bene è stata non era
neanche troppo difficile realtà perché i
ragazzi sono schiantati subito il
problema di paul montene che quando
regna la colonna devi avere la fermezza
di fermarci sulla del gioco di parole
perché se non ti fermi subito rischi di
morire mi è piaciuta bene vedi che alla
fine il walter ha portato fortuna usate
il bate ragazze che comunque ragazzi sta
storia del battere un po strana perché
la latti e una lattina a metà in realtà
l'ultima volta supplì 4 ero due vittorie
di fila
l'ultima volta che ho fatto un
videogioco anche per i cacchi mia era
questa cosa continua dirvela gioco anche
per i gatti miei non mi è più successo
di fare due vittorie di fila però in
video proprio su playstation 4 fatto del
debito linfera quindi proviamo a vedere
se riusciamo questa volta ho anche se la
vicina mi andrebbe bene
partiamo già subito primi tedesca
arrivare almeno primo nel primo nel
primo a livello sequestro king e crash
in genere me la cavo e ragazzi a livello
come di tempistiche mai corre monio come
ho detto che me la cavo sono caduto non
incastrare qui porta ma non fa niente
madonna che brutti che sono a fini
proietti era innamorato del proiettile
ma va a cagare
vorrei vederlo per male io non l'ho
preso l'impianto che culo che culo
finale and that's one
e allora no allora no non è il nono in g
se voi giocate con making sense sappiate
che se ti fischiano le orecchie sono io
col vuvuzela nel vostro tifano perché
nel jeans ed la gente fa cagare mamma
mia mi esce di continuo comunque la
tattica che io utilizzo ragazzi per
jeans vera ripeto se non avete visto in
live giro tantissimo sulla ruota una
delle due ruote appena qualcuno si
lancia sopra dei blu e dei gialli bene
che scuota 6
insomma quella squadra seria minaccia
si sta per lanciare forze eccole come su
100 100 100 perfetto
mamma mia che a rischio sbagliando e
vado nell'altra nell'altra perfetto
perfetto e poi quello ecologista d'aiuto
aiuta sarà l'ultimo
ed eccoci però ce l'ha fatta lui ci
credo perché alla fine non si capisce
alla fine la tattica non vale più perché
non si capisce una sega ragazzi allora
se vinco fourball posso pensare di
vincere anche stavolta la seconda
vittoria perché il problema qual è anche
se vinco fourball rimaniamo in quattro
quindi è molto più fattibile speriamo li
vince perché il sito di football me la
cavo molto bene speriamo che non faccia
teca gare del gruppo arca vacca spingete
pil di zio bravi che ha attirato l'ira
bravi bravi mica vi amo vi amo corretta
al centro nord iraq iniziata a marzo c'è
pure la mia schimdt sente schifoso mo ti
permetti paro paro spinge quanto 90 però
non posso stare solo io al centro che
spinge le palle qualcuno vada sull'altra
ok che siamo in quattro però madonna che
ansia
se prendiamo con gli ammazzo ti ammazzo
io non posso avere i compagni così
idioti non zona ok perfetto buono che
ansia dice la zia spegnerà ok 51 e
rassicurante laga e magari anche 6 bene
dai dai
non è vero
l'abbiamo fatta e di camin almeno che
non c'entra la palla da cinque ragazze
anche la palla da 5 la sottovaluta da
sempre ma c'è una palla che fa fare
cinque punti sto gioco
il caldo che ti sta arrivando al
cervello perfetto madonna ragazzi allora
gran for boys questo mi è piaciuto
bravini compagnone non è sempre era è
raro trovare compagni buoni finale il 4
quindi potrebbero essere anche col monte
in realtà perché in quattro prima è
andata bene ragazzi posso vincere con i
filo realizzato adesso è la playstation
comunque come la play perché non è
possibile col monte va bene va bene e
dilata non cambia niente tra questa expo
perché se siamo in quattro ci può stare
partiamo tutti da davanti quindi nessun
è penalizzato il nome simile al mio zio
mal riuscito requa sarà solo un lorenzo
tanto abbiamo siamo a coppie due della
stessa skin e 2 dell'altra team con
demonio bravo bravo che si è alzato
dio mio non è vero no no mi ammazzo ti
ammazzo
sono proprio le svenuto di compagno ok
dai team i gruppi della palla di vetro
fino al palapicci volano alla una palla
in 300 all'ora una valle in 300 all'ora
una volée tra città allora ti prego
miglia bravissimo quello è stato un po
no sì non è vero non ci credo
c'è di me l'ha già mi fermo un attimo
perché se continuo ad esserlo aperto
sicuro mi fermo un attimo perché c'è un
obiettivo ragazzi giusto gioco dei vinci
n 5 di fila è impossibile ci sono
riusciti in pochissimi nel mondo europeo
che ti sblocca il proprio impossibile da
prendere
si chiama impossibile infatti sono però
già due di fila e tanto vi assicuro che
tantissimo quindi sono contento va bene
ci vediamo le prossimo episodio ragazzi
giovedì sera vi sia piaciuto che come
sempre ci vediamo dunque bisogno di paul
guys lasciato mi piace un commento e ci
rendiamo come sempre al proprio bella
ragazza
[Musica]